so the box up by eight goddess on the  recovery stove so he could have got a  foul ball ten times on that plate  [Applause]  cause the foul again it should not be  understated and I know that wilt and  other players have done this but since  recording this stack of points in the  paint and Caleb of accelerating  [Applause]  the tipsters vanish the rebound  Wow  we are losing all the hustle plays well  look at this they are not losing this  hustle play and to the coop Oh Connor  temple rebound for coffee you want the  Celtics to attack the glass they have  four second chance  this pain poster they say you should get  a jump shot shoot fifty threes a game  poster they say you should get a jump  shot shoot 50 threes again  [Music]  [Applause]  mom you said it Connie Hawkins he said a  little bit of dr. J  [Applause]  mom you said